[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum how are you
it's one of those days i just started
going this podcast was brought to you by
and i was like ryan's like no this is
the beginning of the podcast we're doing
that first we're doing the ads in a
minute lords
goodness we're gonna get to alexander
ludwig if you're here for him please
just listen here and uh i would say if
you like the podcast today all i ask is
like hey let's give this guy a shot
let's let's subscribe to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum and listen
because he you know we like the
interviews we like what he gets out of
people so i hope you'll do that
subscribe on youtube on apple on spotify
pretty much everywhere and write a
review that really helps the podcast and
another thing are our handles you can
follow us and find out what's up with
the old inside of your podcast and the
handles ryan inside of your pod on
twitter at side of your podcast on
instagram and facebook that is correct
yes
i want to say first of all thank you for
everyone for coming out to see me play
music on march 5th last saturday it
meant a lot to me you know who you are i
appreciate it congratulations to all the
winners prizes
um also you can go to the inside of you
online store smallville sign lunch boxes
uh me and welling sign lunch boxes
autographed pictures of lex inside your
mugs inside of you tumblers shirts all
that stuff is at the inside of you
online store you could also go to
sunspin.com and
you could book a zoom with me you could
um buy some cool swag
bandswag and follow us at sunspin at
sunspin band on all the handles i
believe it is
but that really is it and of course i
couldn't do this without my lovable
patrons if you want to give back to the
podcast go to patreon.com
inside of you i will write a message
right after you join within a few days
thanking you
and welcoming you to a wonderful
community so patreon.com inside of you
this guy on the podcast today
really needs no introduction
uh i mean ryan why did you do it anyway
i really enjoyed him yeah i really did
enjoy him and i learned a lot about
alexander ludwig um
country artist which
he's great he really sounds like he
should be on the air yeah uh another
thing uh
the show vikings
a big hit
he was one of the leads in vikings and
now
his show on stars called heels with our
good buddy stephen amell right so we had
to get him on here and he really opens
up he opens up about uh
alcoholism
drug addiction things like that
and i think you're gonna really enjoy
this so without further ado let's get
inside of alexander ludwig it's my point
of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you there bud
what's going on can you hear me
[ __ ] a writes i could hear yeah
that's i'm trying to be canadian right
now [ __ ] right there you hoser
[ __ ] right then
my my buddy's uh
chris prong our name drop but he's a he
plays for the saint louis blues
he's from dryden ontario i mean they
just put his jersey in the rafters last
night
you know and no way and he gave a speech
and then he downed an entire beer like a
true canadian in front of all like 30
000 people he just downed a beer
chris pronger dude that i i remember uh
watching him play as a kid he's amazing
oh yeah he was chippy chippy weren't you
i know he's listening he listens to the
podcast every once in a while he was
always the guy that you wanted to be
when you played the video games
oh yeah in the nhl
yeah
yeah the tough you could just destroy
people you know who's a fan here's
another hockey buddy of mine i told you
about burnsie
uh burns brent burns from san jose
and he's such a beauty he's he
he did a cameo in vikings right
yeah
so we kept in touch a little bit he's
just what a what a good i love when
people i love when good things happen to
good people you know yeah he was a big
fan and he just got to be on vikings it
was like a dream for him he was so
pumped he loves
that show he's like you know alexander
by the way i was thinking about this
because i haven't really
heard someone say your name but like i
think of ludwig ludwig van beethoven so
i think he's got to go by alexander
ludwig
yeah yeah yeah he was actually my like
my great great great grandfather
no he wasn't you [ __ ]
i'm like how's that possible his first
name was ludwig not his last name
it's true i'm just an idiot it wasn't
even worse no i it kind of worked you
still almost got me
people people ask me how i um how i
pronounce my name and i still don't know
like everyone says it differently it's
like my even my parents like sometimes
it's ludwig sometimes it's liquid
sometimes it's ludwig so i just say i
kind of go in between i just say
you say ludwig you know what's funny
because i say
rose and bomb and my dad just gets
pissed off i've talked about this hold
on i'm just making fixing [ __ ] but my
dad says what's your name i go michael
he goes noah your last name i go
rosenbaum he goes
your last name's rosenbaum
i'm like yeah he goes it's rose and baum
i go look buddy i'm not saying hey i'm
michael rosenbaum to everybody i'm just
gonna say it's frozen bomb throw it away
throw it away ludwig i'm alexander
ludwig
he gets so pissed
you know i mean my dad always be he also
like he would always i think it's maybe
that generation too like my dad
my dad always said um you know your name
is not alex it's i named you alexander
you know for a reason right right and
like my buddies should be like hey alex
his name's alexander
you know or like
but now i mean now it's whatever i you
know some people call me xander some
people call me z some people call me
alex
you know i'll give it up can i call you
uh i'll call you wig what's up wig no
people call me litty litty ludwig hey
look what's up
yeah i love it i love it you know
are you you're in canada right now no
i'm in atlanta you're in atlanta what
are you filming are you allowed to say
no yeah no
i mean i moved here when we get in heels
because it's it just i just
i took a shot in the dark and like one
of my biggest regrets when i had vikings
was not buying a place in ireland and i
was just like
you know what
regardless of whether or not heels comes
back i love georgia and like i love the
south so i'm going to move here and it's
close to nashville so for music stuff it
made a lot of sense so we just took a
shot and people thought we were crazy
and now that we're coming back uh we're
geniuses yeah exactly you got the place
in atlanta um yeah because i i didn't
realize this but you really are a
country boy i mean you ride horses you
uh you listen to country music you play
country music i listen to your album and
i was like holy [ __ ] he really digs deep
yeah thank you man thank you so much
like i i
don't know how like it's not like i grew
up on a farm you know i grew up in
vancouver or just just outside but um
i spent all my like my
just all my inspiration came from being
outdoors and being like in the mountains
and my family and i would always go to
montana and ride there and i there's a
dude ranch there and i i just i fell in
love with just that whole way of life
because and i think what i love about it
so much is just to what it speaks to
like especially in our industry
we're always looking for like i think
the next win or the next thing and it's
just a reminder to like just take a step
back and just enjoy the little things
and what actually matters in life you
know yeah do you do that do you still to
this day are you someone who wakes up
goes outside does something outside
outdoors are you always outside are you
because i'm a little bit of a
what's it called ryan a uh hermit
permanent yeah yeah or whatever i kind
of like you know i like staying in the
house it's hard to get me out unless i'm
playing something competitive or a sport
or something like that i don't you know
but i got to try and get out of my
comfort zone this year and start to do
more hikes and things like that but what
do you do to to relieve stress and
things like so what like i
you know i skydive that was like um i
have my a license so that's something
that i would do but when i'm under
contract i can't do that so i i love
surfing but i'm not in l.a so now
um you know we i do my dream is to
always have a ranch i've always wanted
to have a ranch and um
preferably a ranch on the lake which is
a this is a hard one to do but that is
that is the dream and um
you know i when i first moved to atlanta
we like i was spending all my time
outside building [ __ ] you know just
trying to learn because i've never
really had a place where i can do that
uh but now
um
like especially like these next couple
weeks it's just been like i i spent a
week like last week doing absolutely
nothing for like the first time in a
long time because i was just so burnt
out and
just like i need to just
turn it off um
but like i'm usually like writing music
or i love i love being outside i love
hiking like i do love being in nature
but i wouldn't say that like
hiking is my jam like i love like rock
climbing or like
just something where
you know like i noticed that i've been
spending too much time inside so i
wouldn't get a jiu jitsu class this
morning you know like stuff like that so
i try to get try to do stuff right but
um
but yeah not
you know it's
it's difficult you know like with our
life it's there's just no structure so
it's really hard to
turn like okay well i'm not working
right now so it's like i need to have my
own plan and my own structure so yeah
have you ever not been in good shape
every role i see you in you're ripped
i mean whether it's vikings or whether
it's heels playing the wrestler or
whatever it is you're always
you know national champions i mean i can
go on but like
is it something that's just part of your
routine like you have to work out
because you just enjoy it or do you work
out because it's part of your you know
your career
when i was in high school i i was a
really late bloomer
and me too i think that i think that
really kind of [ __ ] me up mentally
like i think i didn't realize at the
time but i was like you know like
everybody's chasing girls and i'm just
like what the hell like you know what's
going on yeah no hair on the balls yeah
i experienced the same thing not a
i used to pray for pubes i swear to god
i go to bed at night and go dear lord
give me pubes dear lord
like really though like that [ __ ] messes
you up as a kid and you know especially
when you're when your friends are like
amazing athletes that are you know and
you know i
and then when i finally hit you know
puberty i think i i got mono so i lost
like a ton of weight and
i think right after i got over that i
was like
i am
i am just making a serious lifestyle
change and i literally lived in the gym
and i think ever since then i felt so
good and i think ever since then i just
like it's more just for mental health
than anything like i just like
i like feeling good like i just i feel
really
like you know my head just gets really
weird if i haven't
exercised you said your head gets weird
do you mean you get sort of down in the
dumps depressed or anxious
or just like you know just i just don't
feel centered um
so i think that just working out has
kind of always been just a part of my my
life
and i you know i miss sports and i miss
so i'm trying to find a way to do that
you know it's hard like with
you know
like with our industry it's like you're
not really allowed to do anything that i
really love doing you know when you're
like on a series like
i can't just like goes kind of you know
go climb something you know
wait a minute you can't do that stuff
but you could throw your body around in
a
in a wrestling ring and just destroy
yourself but you can't do that you
destroy yourself on our time
not on your time
isn't that what happens that's exactly
what happens they're paying you a lot of
money they want you to be you know be
alive they want you to
be on set so they could destroy you do
you do a lot of your own [ __ ] like on
the heels by the way guys is on stars
it's uh it's awesome it's like amateur
wrestling right
yeah yeah it's about what's that i mean
it's yeah it's like it's about pro
wrestling in small town georgia and
um you know these guys with with big
dreams i want to make another small town
and um you know i've never i i wouldn't
say that traditionally i was like
brought up on it or something that i was
like crazy about even though i didn't
watch it as a kid but um
that whole way of life is just so
fascinating to me um just what these
guys put their bodies and minds through
for like
for their dreams is really inspiring i
mean these guys they use and abuse their
bodies on a regular basis they got no
help and they're just driving from town
to town just to you know it's it's their
version of the of the nhl right yeah or
the nfl or whatever so um
i became an actor to be able to tell
stories about things that even i don't
know about so that was that was really
exciting yeah
but yeah like
you know
it's so funny i love when i hear actors
go like oh yeah like i do all my own
stunts i'm like you're so full of [ __ ]
man there's one person in the world that
does all his own stunts that's tom
cruise
is a is a certified stunt man and you
know like when you get to that level i
think you can
you can
demand certain things you know like but
for me
like i will happily do stunts but it's
it's just you know um you're not an
idiot you know when to walk away yeah
and also not to mention like you know
this like stunt men make an adjustment
on a son so it's like when you don't you
know like you want to look out for your
your fellow stuntman too so but like
steven and i talked about this and like
you can't really fake it yeah when
you're when you're doing a show like
fuels like you can't you can't just like
fake wrestling in the rings like most of
that stuff we learn to do and i would
say 90 of it we did do but there's
certain things that you know we have
incredible some guys do like fall off of
the top of the cage like they're not
letting us do that there's just no way
and
it'd be stupid of me to do that because
we don't need to it's probably hard to
stop a male though
stephen stephen likes to do he loves
wrestling more than anybody and i i know
that he likes to do his own stuff and he
gets injured and things like that but he
goes the extra mile doesn't he
for sure and that's one thing i love
about him too like
um i didn't know what to expect when we
first met each other and you know for me
i've always gone into like stuff just
with the mindset of
um look we don't have to be best friends
but let's just show up and put give 110
to everything we do and remember how
grateful we are and stephen was that and
more like he's a brother to me and i
love him and he cared so much about this
um
you know that he's he's got such a
soft spot for wrestling and he's such a
massive fan of it so he was such an
asset to me and we really pushed each
other i think to just get the best
performance as possible i mean
the last episode of heels i swear to god
the crew thought we killed each other
because
we
we went all out and um and i'm so
grateful to have like just like you know
a partner who would do that with me do
you like that do you like that intensity
where you're like i don't is it a
feeling of i don't know if he's really
serious right now but i'm gonna like
you're keeping up almost like are we
fighting right now is he going he's
doing a little more than i thought he
was going to do that we talked about
yeah i love that like we like we did a
take we did a take and i remember we
looked we saw it back and we were like
nah
like this isn't working and we're like
all right let's do one let's go all out
on one this is going to really hurt and
it's going to suck but let's do it like
100 let's go and that was i mean that's
fun as hell and you feel like you just
like went
went to war together or something you
know like you're just like wow we
really really did that were you hurt did
you get what did you feel afterwards
like oh my god what hurt on you or him
um oh man dude like
wrestling hurts your body in ways that
you never could have that i could have
expected i mean you're just sore
everywhere and like
i mean and it's always the things i i
never would have expected that like the
crazy stunts don't hurt nearly as much
as like like the simple bumps like when
you're just falling flat back and you're
just like your bell is wrong and you're
just like
man
that was like it's like the weirdest
feeling uh and you really gotta go into
it or i mean it's like it's like
anything i guess they'd say the same
football it's like if you go in half
half-assed like that's when you get hurt
right
so like when you're tackling a guy or
anything so
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy
everybody knows these guys
everybody loves them i love them ryan
that's great yeah yep it's helping you
getting a lot out of it amen
look folks relationships take work
especially the most important one you
can have in your life and that is your
relationship with yourself a lot of us
will drop anything to go help someone we
care about we'll go out of our way to
treat other people well but how often do
we give ourselves the same treatment
it's true we don't we're not good to
ourselves enough
and you got to be good to yourself and
you'll learn how to be good to yourself
but one of those things you could do is
join
better help this month better help
online therapy wants to remind you that
you matter just as much as everyone else
does and therapy is a great way to make
sure you show up for yourself ryan what
would you say better help is doing for
you
uh it is helping me to uh
learn
about myself better uh how to treat
myself better uh
and just talking about things that are
bothering me however big or small yeah
because sometimes you think oh i have
friends to talk to you i have
no you you can't be
absolutely open with your thoughts and
your demons and your thing just with
friends or you know people think they
take it it's so
easy you know like oh i don't need to
worry about that and it builds up and it
builds up and it festers and
we all implode at some point so we got
to take care of ourselves and better
help online therapy is there to help us
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours
give it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy this podcast is sponsored by
better help and inside of you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash
inside
thank you better help
couldn't do it without you
inside of you is brought to you by
magic spoon
i don't know about you but as a kid i
loved eating cereal i love the boxes and
all the flavors and and just but as an
adult you start to realize ryan that you
know that wasn't really good for me
and it sucks because you love cereal you
love the taste of cereal but what if i
told you that you could still have
cereal in a healthier way
i'd love to hear that well you're gonna
hear it
magic freaking spoon magic spoon growing
up cereal is one of the best parts of
being a kid but i had to give it up
because i realized it was full of sugar
and junk that you really shouldn't eat
we're all trying to eat better but
healthy breakfast doesn't have to be
boring magic spoon has the amazing
flavors you love but without all the bad
stuff and it's amazing as a midnight
stack right before
bed
i've been trying to cut down the carbs
the sugar the unhealthy food and realize
basically i can't eat anything anymore
ryan
but
i can have this
i could have magic spoon tell me what's
in
magic spoon zero grams of sugar 13 to 14
grams of protein and only 4 net grams of
carbs in each serving only 140 calories
a serving well it's keto friendly gluten
free grain free soy free and low carb
build your own box available flavors to
build your own custom bundle are coco
fruity frosted peanut butter blueberry
cinnamon cookies and cream and maple
waffle
i like peanut butter it's always been my
favorite it's delicious it reminds me of
i won't say
but that's what it reminds me of that's
good and it's just tasty it's taste you
can eat it whenever you want ryan
whenever you want no one can tell you
anything listen folks go to
magicspoon.com
iou to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and be sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order
a lot of my friends say is this magic
spoon good i know you have to read these
spots but is it good
i'm like yeah why don't you taste it so
i had a tasting contest not a contest
but tasting a tasting
and i gave it to like four different
friends like dude
this is pretty good
they were all really surprised magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's back with a hundred percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked i don't know
who wouldn't want to get it then
it's pretty self-explanatory you get a
box of the cereal that you know you're
gonna like and if you don't like it
they'll return it try it give it a shot
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com iou
and use the code iou to save five
dollars off thank you magic spoon for
sponsoring this
podcast so talking about that because
you get you know beaten and battered
doing these things and it's amazing how
you kind of went all for it and just
said [ __ ] it and the producers are like
let's go don't hurt each other just you
know but you know keep in mind we've got
another season hopefully to do here and
then you do it and then they get it but
stephen says he wants a plunge pool like
you have and he says he's serious he
wants you to promise him on the podcast
right now that you'll hook him up
all right stephen i'll kill for the
blindfold i know the owner i i was
really lucky i i saw this thing on
online and i just
i was uh
during kobe like during our quarantine i
was so bored and i was like i want to
talk to somebody who i'm like fast by
and wim hof was somebody who i just i
admire so much the i don't know if you
know anything about hockey he's he
called me ice man and he basically
like
invented cold plunge therapy um and he
he basically he's broken numerous world
records he does not get sick they
injected him with e coli and his body
beat it and he's fascinating so i ended
up getting on like
on like a live um
instagram with him and so i've asked him
all these questions and um i've always
loved the cold water it's like i just
feel like when you're in that much pain
and you're like you just you have to go
inwards and you have to kind of just
like breathe through it it's really how
cold how cold are we talking about here
you plunge when you plunge into this
water how cold is this water
yeah so like i'm trying to think in i
think my well freezing's 32 degrees okay
so my plunge pool is at like 43 or 42.
and how long can you stay in this plunge
pool well i did i did i did 15 minutes
which was way too long i did 15 minutes
and then i was just like shivering the
whole day so usually i try to do like
five
five minutes um
or so you know it's just like an ice
bath you know after a workout or
something and you do this all the time
i try yeah i mean i tried it right now
it's yeah i had to i moved on to this
like structure in the backyard so i got
to fill it back up again but yeah
usually i try to do it like every day or
every other day
dude i look at your
all the stuff you've done i mean you
know you got heals the vikings which was
huge you played bjorn right bjorn
and that was huge
uh hunger games national champions lone
survivor
you got them you get all these things
first of all i want to know with all
these you've worked with big actors i
mean sandler and
marky mark or what's wahlberg mark
wahlberg i always i still think mark you
[ __ ] said mark marky mark before and
it got in my head but wahlberg who i
love
um
jennifer lawrence right
so
there's got to be it of all these
great actors
or icons someone had to be an [ __ ]
you can't work with guys that are just
awesome all the time dude i i just said
this i did i did a podcast yesterday
actually and i just said this same thing
and i i stand by this man like whether
it's will smith mark wahlberg
anthony hopkins you know any of those
the people that i've been fortunate
enough to work with the one thing they
have all had in common is that they are
good people and i mean really
really
good people i mean they're businessmen
there's no doubt um but they treat
everyone with respect and they're humble
and um
and
that
that gave me so much hope because i
realized
that
kindness does win at the end it really
does you know like like
i feel like most of the people who and i
haven't really worked with [ __ ] ever
like i really mean that like i've
usually been able to get i work with
people who other people thought were
[ __ ] but i've never had that
experience and i just feel like
usually
you can find some sort of commonality or
a way to you know have some sort of
camaraderie on anything you do but
um
i just feel like sometimes it's the
people who aren't
where they want to be you know and are
lacking that gratitude that are really
really frustrating the guys who think
they deserve more they they certainly
deserve 100 and i think
all those guys at the top
have done something they're all so
they're all so well spoken and they have
mastered themselves and i think that
you know some some people always ask me
alexander like why do you do all this
stuff or like why do you speak the way
you do and i'm just like man like
in this business you know this too like
you have to master your emotions to
survive
like if you don't um this business will
eat you up because you know it is so
easy especially when you're starting out
to compare yourself and to look around
and and feel less than um
and when you realize comparison is the
fifi joy and i'm gonna put my horse
blinders on and i'm gonna put one foot
in front of the other and and not look
left not look right be grateful that i'm
getting paid to do what i love um then
the world is your oyster and it's so
much easier to preach it than live it
like don't get me wrong like we all have
our days but um
that's that is the huge takeaway i've
taken from all these people is just an
immense amount of gratitude and
um
you know don't i mean everybody has a
bad day but
i'm sure
i'm sure martin lawrence had a bad day
dude
martin blew my mind i mean i've heard
stories of
martin from back in the day
that man is
is really special i love him did you
ever see the movie life he's genius yeah
and he gave me the time of day like you
never would expect i remember when we
finished bad boys i bought them about
willa martinez like necklace that said
like bad boys on it was this gold
necklace that i had this like this
jewelry company engraved you know bad
boys on i gave one to my wonder will and
martin wore it to the wrap party
you know and wow
yeah you know like he's just one you
know
he's just such a good dude and his
buddies that he's his sister is amazing
the buddies he surrounds himself with
they're all so i don't know what he was
like back in the day but whatever
whatever it was i i had nothing i have
nothing but incredible things to say
about that and he's just so lovely and
just was there to work i remember he i
was a guest on conan o'brien and he was
the main guest and i was just sitting in
my you know room kind of a little
nervous you know right before and also
there's a knock on the door
and it opens up and it's martin lawrence
i'm like because i had told somebody i'm
like oh i'm a big martin lawrence fan
and he looks at me he's like he's like
hey man what's up
and i go hey dude he's like hey you do
your thing on there man you do your
thing on there and i'm like you know he
just came over gave me a hug and then i
quoted the movie life and he go i just
said something like oh damn ray i got my
big toe caught in a bottle and he just
started like what how do you know that
you know he just like is a random random
quote from this movie and he was so
sweet that's why i thought because i
heard stories too but my
meeting with him he went out of his way
to be kind so i hear you
i love that and like imagine like and
that's the other thing is like i think
it's really important to hold judgment
until you meet somebody in person
because yeah like
imagine if everyone was watching you
all hours of the day i mean we've all
had a bad day at a supermarket or at a
[ __ ] gas station i mean like we you
know what i mean like the difference is
that this has become so public i think
um
i can't imagine that that kind of toll
it would take on you so
i mean i i absolutely love
marty mar and i can't wait to work with
him again you said some you said thief
of joy comparing yourself to others is
yeah comparison is the thief comparison
is the thief of joy
boy we you know in this podcast we we
definitely talk about comparing
yourselves to other people and like why
does he have that and why don't i have
that and why i'm this and you know we
all do it i've done it and it's the
thief of joy i like well put well put
yeah i mean it's important you know it's
so important to remember like
even the shittiest days man there's
somebody in the hospital with [ __ ]
covered right now begging to be in our
position you know or
cancer or anything and you know
i i think it's natural to want more and
to want to push yourself um
i always tell people
trust that it's going to happen
just never how you expect it to or when
you expect it to right and and you know
enjoy that journey that that is life
because
anything that i missed out on um looking
back it's the
it was the blessing in disguise you know
or anything i thought that was a bad
experience are no bad experiences
because it makes you who you are now
yeah
yeah and you're only 29 is that right
yeah you're 29 years old
you seem like such an old soul
like you know i mean like you've kind of
lived in a lot of ways i i don't know if
working in ireland and kind of being
thrown into that kind of
you learned a lot i don't know what it
is
all my friends were you know my whole
life have been in their
40s 30s or 40s or 50s like because
that's that you know i've been working
since i was a kid so i think that that's
just the kind of people i always
gravitated to and then i think just by
osmosis i started just picking up things
and
you know you kind of got to grow up
quick in this
in this business um as well but i
certainly don't feel young anymore like
you know what i mean like i i was just
talking to my buddy i'm like you know
i'm about to be 30 and
again this is another thing like
you gotta check yourself on this [ __ ]
it's like
man i'm just i'm about to be 30 like
aren't i supposed to be here it's like
hold on hold on like stop putting these
[ __ ] time
time frames you know because we all have
those that we have this clock in our
head like oh man like i'm oh man i'm 40.
i'm supposed to be here at 40s you know
you're supposed to be exactly where you
are yeah 49 here buddy i'm about to be
50.
no you're not yeah yeah i'm gonna be 50
this year can you believe it no you're
so full of [ __ ] i swear to god and i
will say this i don't dye my my hair
i don't dye my hair i get i get a few
grays i feel like [ __ ] but i don't have
gray hair
i actually don't believe you i swear to
god look at look online i'm 50. i mean i
could play 41 with makeup
when you say ryan i would i have more
gray hairs than you yeah i don't get a
lot of gray hairs i don't work enough
you can play 35 man
i wish
no
what i'm telling you are you looking it
up
yeah
he's actually looking up to see how old
and i'm telling you i'm probably 50.
dude that's funny yeah i know man it's
it's it's pretty crazy hey you've been
um you've been doing this like you said
since you were a kid you've been doing
did your mother and father want you to
act is it something that they've
supported or is it something that
they're like you you're not doing this
it was actually the latter yeah they i
my mom actually used to be an actress
and um
she was in friday the 13th part eight
get out yeah i uh
claimed the fame and that's right really
talented and she you know i she i really
wouldn't be here without her like she
was
i told my parents that this is what i
wanted to do
when i was about nine
and they were like
um no there's no way we're gonna there's
no supporting
you're insane but how i took it was that
they believed i could do it and that's
why they were scared
you know like like what if he gets
success early and what if this happens
you look at all these young kids who've
had success
um and they get so messed up by it um
but fortunately you know i ended up
stealing my mom's phone calling her old
age and asking for a meeting
and uh you called her old agent yeah and
asked for a meeting yeah because i knew
her name so i called her and i asked for
a meeting how old were you at this point
how old at that point i was probably
like 12 when i ended up doing that or no
i was no i was probably nine actually
you were nine you call your mom's age
and say i want to be in front of 13th
part 9. now what do you say what do you
say to this agent and i'm like hey my
name is alexander and like i i want to
be an actor and i know you used to
represent my mom and like just give me a
shot won't let you down
um and then she was like fine i guess
i'll give this you know this kid a shot
and i went out for my first audition
ever and i booked it and it was
a harry potter toy commercial
called the slime chamber and today it's
the best payday ever because they gave
me the toy
and like i
i and obviously like what a way to start
and and then of course i realized
shortly after just how hard this was
going to be and then over the years i
got very lucky like i was never really
catapulted i was always just constantly
working but never catapulted into
something that i couldn't really handle
at the time
um
wow which i'm grateful for that's guts
man that's guts as a little
nine-year-old calling mama's agent
yeah
you know that's hilarious and then i
mean you so you started getting some
success right after that right it just
from there you kind of took off and
started doing these movies right these
little movies
yeah like i started doing like tv like
movies of the week and commercials and
all that and then i booked my first big
gig that you know
was
like really did change my life which was
called the seeker the dark is rising i
was 13 years old and i had a casting
director in vancouver really really bad
for me fox studios flew me out i did
like 16 auditions for this party
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait did
you come on seriously you did 16
auditions i [ __ ] you not it was it was
because i was so green and i was such a
kid
like
they
liked me a lot but they didn't know if i
could do it um and
i was up against like
the kids who i would realize i would be
up against for the next 10 years for
stuff you know it was always the same
group of people and um he booked one job
and i booked the other and it was like
um but that movie was supposed to be
like that like harry potter that's what
they had thought about it like this will
be the next harry potter because
obviously it was a big bomb for the
studio but it was an amazing experience
after i booked the roll within a week my
mom and i were off to romania and i we
shot there for three and a half months
and
you know all along the way she had
you know at times when i didn't believe
in myself she always believed in me and
i really wouldn't
have
this career without my mom she really
was my
my saving grace she knew how badly i
wanted to do it and
um she supported me the whole way i saw
a picture on your instagram of you and
your mother i think it was at an airport
or something yeah yeah that's kind of
why this is like at the top of my mind
because it was her birthday like a
couple of days ago it was her birthday
yeah
she's probably my age
don't worry are you sure
yeah
i don't know i mean seriously i'm 50
here you could probably be my son you
could
you're almost my son at one point no i'm
kidding
um no that's that's insane so you're you
have this bond with your mom she just
pushed you through it someone who really
tried to discourage you in a way
to not be in this because she knew how
hard it was
and the whole business how dirty it can
be and you were motivated and you
decided to do it and then she was right
there with you during the whole thing
yeah without without a doubt oh it's
funny mike o'malley's calling me right
now from heels mike o'malley created
heels correct
telling me you're doing an interview
with michael rosenbaum he put a song in
the second episode of heels
one of our songs from my album
are you serious yeah you can hear it in
the background it's kind of background
music but it's from my band sunspin uh
it's it's it's a it's actually a scene
with mike o'malley at a table in a
restaurant and uh
uh what is it called
summertime neighbors playing in the
background i was i was pumped i was like
thanks dude i didn't know why you did
music it's awesome yeah it's completely
different from yours but i think you i
think you'll appreciate it hopefully i
don't know it's it's not for everybody
but it's for some and yeah the band's
sun spin and you just go alexander
ludwig right
yeah that's that's a bit do you get
weird when you hear your music or you
like hearing it
um i mean around other people do you get
kind of like nervous because i mean this
look it's it's so country it sounds like
it could be on the radio right now i
mean it should be on the radio it sounds
like something everybody in indiana
where i grew up would be listening to on
the radio right now wgbf yeah i really
really appreciate that it's um yeah like
i'm
like it
i think i'm just that way i think i've
realized that you know you i'm just that
way with everything and i think maybe a
lot of artists are it's just like
like
you always feel you can be better you
can be better you can do better so it's
hard it's hard sometimes to sit back uh
and just appreciate what you have done
um right what do you what do you what do
you think when you listen to that right
now what's the first thing that goes
through your mind
when i listen to that just there i was
like oh yeah that does sound pretty good
all right there you go
yeah so i appreciate it like you were
also like pumping up my tires that was
nice it's um
but you know like that that how that all
happened is just a truth true fluke
i i realized that like i've been writing
music my whole life and i realized that
um i had this real short window of time
to pursue it if i wanted to right after
i finished vikings and i was like you
know what i'm going to take a shot at
this
so i started hopping on planes going to
nashville i had no
direction whatsoever and i just started
meeting whoever i could
writing with whoever i could
and i told them the same thing which was
that
you know this is not a vanity project
for me like this is really my life and i
i want to do this as long as i can so
i'm not expecting a record deal i'm not
expecting anything i just want to keep
coming back and
um one you know about a year into me
taking these plane these trips to
nashville this this band
came up to me um
in the airport and said they were big
fans of lone survivor and they're like
what are you doing going to nashville
and i was like well when i wasn't
shooting vikings on the weekends i was
in the studio recording it a demo
and you know country music has always
held a really close place in my heart
and i i'm trying to figure it out um and
i was like you guys are obviously a band
uh who do you play for and they go uh
jason mountain
now jason is like one of the biggest
country artists oh yeah
and somebody who i grew up listening to
and who i love and who has since become
a really close friend um yeah i i ended
up sitting behind
behind the band behind tully in specific
who's like
uh jason he produces with jason he also
plays bass for him and i sit right
behind him on the plane and we talked
the entire way so it was really a fluke
and by the end of it we ended up working
together
and then
bmg caught on who signed jason and
um we got a meeting and uh signed the
record deal and and
from my understanding we're gonna drop
the album uh this year
which will be great is the album done is
the album done the album's done uh i
mean i always want to keep you know you
know me like i i just i always want to
keep making it better so it's never done
until it's done but yeah we've got more
than enough songs does he sing on the
album
no no um
jason doesn't but i mean i
i mean i would love to do something with
jason
yeah but you kind of said has anybody
ever told you you kind of have a little
there's there's a little
uh kenny chesney in there
yeah
have you heard that
yeah i mean i get that a lot and that's
obviously the greatest greatest
compliment ever of course
i grew up to like you know i grew up
listening to kenny and i i love them so
much and um
randomly i ended up in the same kind of
uh
everybody in nashville knows each other
so um you know i started writing with a
lot of the guys that wrote a lot of
kenny songs as well and um
you know i'm a huge massive fan of him
so that's i mean that's just nothing but
a compliment if i can be 10 as uh as
great as he is i'll you know i'll be
happy so so you're really going after it
you want to continue doing the acting as
hard as you can and you want to have a
music career
that's what i said to the the president
of the label i just said man like
i'm here for the long haul i'm not going
anywhere and
i i
i love this so
i believe that now is a very interesting
time uh more than ever people can do
both if they can manage their time
properly
and i'm fortunate to be in a place right
now with my career where i have a little
bit more say
into like what my schedule looks like
right don't get me wrong if one scorsese
called me up tomorrow that's a different
story but but for the most part you know
we we have a we have a pretty good idea
of what the year will look like which
means that i can be like okay this is
what i'm doing heels this is what i'm
going on tour
and then this is what i'm doing x y z so
um
you know they were they're on board and
you know it's it's naive to think that
it will happen any quicker than my
my uh my acting like it's going to take
you years and years and years but it's
okay
i love doing it all you need is one hit
song someone to support you or someone
there to
plug it in change your life three
minutes change your life that should be
a song write a song called three minutes
will change your life it sounds like me
in the bedroom
my uh
longer than i am trust me ryan didn't
like it or maybe you did
it was relatable i think it's relatable
to everybody except porn stars
um did they put any songs of yours and
heels
no they haven't but there's one that we
wrote that i love called rough around
the edges that um i want to put in heel
season 2. uh mike's all about it we were
trying to find a spot for it so
when it makes sense we're going to clear
him for sure
inside of you is brought to you by
patreon that's p-a-t-r-e-o-n guys
patreon these people give back to the
podcast and it's an amazing community
and i message them after they join and i
love this and if you're a patron thank
you if you're joining thank you uh folks
if you enjoy the podcast you love
talking about episodes you want to stay
involved with the inside of your
community i highly suggest that you
check out what we're doing on our
patreon it's quickly turned into one of
the coolest things i've been a part of
over the last year for sure if you want
to get early access to episode content
check out the patreon if you want to
interact with other fans of the show
check out the patreon if you want to get
exclusive access to have your questions
asked during the show
check out the patreon heck if you just
love what we do and want to keep this
train rolling uh maybe check out the
patreon doesn't take much to get
involved and i'm there all the time
chatting with folks and putting together
live hangouts i i literally would not be
able to do this without my patrons they
really make this podcast possible i love
them to get more involved in the
community today head over to patreon.com
inside of you that's p-a-t-r-e-o-n
patreon.com
inside of you and i will see you there
soon
dude you're so open you know in 2019 you
disclosed a whole bunch of stuff like
personal like you were you know you went
through depression anxiety which a lot
of people on this show talk about like
zach levi has come out with you know his
mental well-being and and stephen amell
has come on and talked about it i mean
is that something that you're
comfortable talking about about like you
know dealing with depression and anxiety
and and substance abuse and all that
[ __ ] or is it something
no absolutely it's funny actually my mom
when i signed on to do heels my mom
called me and was like hey like i didn't
realize that stephen
has been open about some of this stuff
like that's crazy and we've bonded over
that you know
um
like
i basically
went through like a really really rough
time
and i mean it was bad it wasn't like
you know like it starts off just like
you know you're hanging out with friends
and everything's fine and then you
realize that there's something like
inside of you that's you know
that you're kind of just trying to hide
and
um i ended up long story short like i
ended up checking myself into rehab for
like 50 days
in arizona and i just was like
i'm going to lose my my career or even
worse my life if i don't put this
together and
like i want to be a good father and a
good husband and a good friend and
i'll be none of those if i don't get
myself in check so that was an
incredible experience one of the
greatest experiences of my life
and uh
yeah man it's been it's been a hell of a
journey and it's really crazy to be on
the other side of it i mean it's never
done but um
having people reach out
now that are my friends or people i look
up to
uh for help and you realize just how
wide this is
i mean you know i lost a friend to
addiction
uh
six days ago
wow so yeah it's like i'm sorry
you know it was heartbreaking man he was
22 years old and such a cute kid and
it's just like
there's no reason why that that
shouldn't have been me
and um because you were that bad
oh yeah yeah like i would go missing for
days and
like it was
you know i just think i had a lot of
demons i had to really
the hardest part is like i think
you
you medicate with whatever you have and
whether it's drugs or alcohol and
um
and suddenly when you get sober it's a
really scary period in your life because
what was your
higher power for lack of a better word
what you would turn to whenever you were
feeling you know
down
or out
it's not there anymore and now you gotta
actually like deal with these issues so
there's no magic i always tell people
who are like struggling with addiction
there's no magic pill like you have to
really want this like you have to really
want a better life but there is a better
life you know i've been sober for almost
four years and it's
it's um
it's remarkable
how much the universe can reward you in
ways you've never expected when you
finally decide to love yourself yeah
that's the hardest thing in the world
i've talked about it before is
loving yourself it sounds so
cliche and like you gotta love yourself
before you can love someone else but you
know it's it's [ __ ] true it's true
and it's hard to love yourself i mean
it's it seems like of course you should
love yourself everybody loves themselves
but like really answering that in front
of a mirror when you're alone
is a different story
and i've been i've struggled with that
i've you know i don't know you know i
definitely have my demons and
insecurities and thoughts of like
you know they're gonna find you out
you're not really that good you're not
really that you know and not i'm being
so hard on myself so lately i've lately
i say the last couple of years i went to
a treatment center too but it wasn't it
wasn't for substance abuse it was just
i felt like
completely lost
completely just lost and my friends were
all surprised when i said i'm going
someplace for three weeks and i just
need to clear my head and they're like
because i'm always the guy who organizes
sports and activities for everybody and
has people over the house and
they're like what
and i was like yeah i just got to do
this for me and it was amazing going
there because
it was cathartic is the word because you
go there and i i felt like nothing could
help me and then you start to talk to
people who you feel like really care
about you
and you start to let out these emotions
that you never thought you had
that you never thought things from the
past affected you and
it's kind of like clean and chop it's
like hey man i got to take care of my
body it's like you know
mental health and therapy is just as
important as
working out and all these other things
they they go hand in hand in a lot of
ways and
so i get it not loving yourself that's a
did you learn in those 50 days to love
yourself
i learned like tools that i think that
like
i think that
loving yourself is so much deeper it's
definitely something like it's an active
you know everyday you know comes with
its own its own struggles and some days
are easier than others you know but um i
certainly realized what the issues
uh that were that were kind of
influencing this uh
this feeling i had about myself were and
and how
and and what i could do to kind of start
addressing it you know and
um
like
like you talked about being the guy who
you know that what you did is like the
hardest thing like that is the hardest
thing like to leave for even three weeks
like that like
most people never give themselves that
you know that's that is a
like that is so brave to just be like
look i haven't i have an issue and i'm
again this is what i always say to
people that are stuck in it is like
you
it is not your fault
that you are an addict or that something
happened to you or that you were beaten
or that you know
whatever happened to you as a kid
happened but it is your fault
if you do nothing about it because your
life is entirely your responsibility and
that's essentially what it is in rehab
is it's just you learn to take
responsibility for your own life and for
the person
that you are the person you want to be
and
um
you know i i i always say like i wish
everybody could experience a version of
it because
you realize like i was in i was in there
with homeless people who had just come
off the streets um with nothing and that
were coming off meth to
billionaires who had invented
world-changing technologies and it was
like it did not matter who you were or
what you did everybody had the same
issue and everybody we all bonded over
the fact that we were trying to get
better and that was that was a really
really special time
wow well i commend you for for opening
up and talking about it because
it's you know it's it's something that i
i i love hearing stories and it just if
anything it's going to help somebody
else out there they're like well that's
why i like talking about it is like i
remember like what part of what really
helped me get through it too was like
i started like doing some deep digging
into like is am i alone here like is
there yeah are there other and then i
start to realize oh my god like
he's sober he's so he's so i'm like [ __ ]
like
like i got nothing to hide like i'd
rather just live my truth
you know what is it what is it you do
now like in terms of like if you're
anxious or you feel that feeling coming
on and you're like you think about that
it's almost like withdrawing from
cigarettes you know i know what's going
on you're like i just need a cigarette i
just need one i just need you let it and
all of a sudden it will pass
that will pass is that what happens
those feelings just slowly pass and you
you you distract yourself with something
healthy
yeah for sure i mean a lot of it is like
they always in a they always talk about
like halt it's like you hungry angry
lonely tired or thirsty like checking
with all those first it's so true like
so many so much so much of the time and
like i wanna wanna drink or whatever
like it's one of those and then um
it's just really like meditation is
really important and something i need to
like sobriety is truly like a game of
uh it's an early man's game it's a game
of just like being accountable and being
okay i'm gonna meditate today i'm gonna
work out i'm gonna eat healthy so i'm
not doing those things is when i feel
myself getting into trouble and covid
was a really really tough time for a lot
of people
um
yeah obviously
um especially people i knew who were
struggling with addiction because
there was your community you kind of
lost you know it's like that idea of
going to meetings and doing all that so
i really felt for a lot of people um
through that but um yeah for me it's
just it it's just
every day is it's it's it's a new day
it's a beautiful day and it comes with
its own challenges you know but we're
just lucky to be here is it are you more
apt to say
yeah kind of like myself a little more
than i used to i mean is that safe to
say or
without a doubt oh my god man like i'm a
better husband brother
you know friend is like it's night and
day
um i'm still the same guy and i just
think that so much of my identity was i
was never i was never an [ __ ] like i
was always nice to people but i think so
much of my identity came from taking
care of others whether it was posting
everybody at a party or or being the guy
right like that was the thing and then
you then i realized man this is like
serving everyone but me
and like i'm not
like this is all ego driven it's not
this is not
how i want my life to be like i want to
grow as a human being not just stay here
you know
yeah you're absolutely right sometimes
you gotta the most important thing is
you take care of you if you can't you
can't take care of anybody else until
you take care of yourself
that's for sure all right this is called
uh [ __ ] talking with alexander ludwig
and these are these are fast if you want
or you can answer them any way you want
but these are from my patrons these are
people who follow the podcast get back
to the podcast so they had some
questions for you and you could just you
know spit them out
able able f if you could create a
spin-off of a character you did not
played in your career what
who but i did play in my career
i guess so yeah that's it play what
would it be and what would that pilot
look like
and it would be it would be about uh
beard iron side for sure because there's
so much to that character that we didn't
get to his foreign vikings um i wish we
did a whole season in africa because he
went to we filmed in morocco for like a
week
but
that there's a whole season there that
that could have been just
vikings in africa which i think is so
fascinating and you shaved your head too
are you you shaved your head for vikings
didn't you yeah i mean not many people
shaved their head i shaved my head for
smallville you shaved your head for
vikings yeah that's true
yeah we got that in common
uh you know it's crazy man too like i i
just the world is so i'm sure you've had
these experiences too but one thing i
love about this industry like i grew up
like watching smallville like i grew up
watching you well i did it's like it's
so crazy now to be like
man like we know each other it's just
it's so funny how small this industry
becomes yeah i agree
joey l how intense was it learning the
fighting scenes on vikings
uh
it you know the learning that wasn't as
hard as like doing them because um when
you're like it's more like learning a
dance
choreography but um we had like some of
the fight scenes we had more extras than
they had on braveheart
and
like
literally i'll never forget one of my
favorite experiences like we were you
know i was leading the charge this one
maybe probably like 600 people and then
on the other side there were like
600 people and like
50 something horses
and we had to run into each other
and like i felt like do you remember
that scene in beaufinger when they're
like yeah like uh hey man like run run
run over the freeway like they're all
paid they're both paid stunt actors
you'll be fine
i'm i was like
so like are we just supposed to dodge
these horses like yeah
like awesome let's go and literally like
you have these horses within like five
feet of you
galloping past you as you clash into
another group of people
like
[ __ ] like that just like
what is my life right now that sounds
dangerous as [ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah
michelle k what is up with you in the
number seven
oh
good uh good question i i don't know i
was i was born on may 7th i weighed
seven pounds and seven ounces
born seven minutes to seven
which i think is pretty cool wow
my birthday's 7-eleven so i'm always
about seven and 11. so i understand it i
understand little lisa what has been
your favorite scene you've done with
steven and mel on heels was it that one
scene you're telling me about where you
guys go balls out yeah that that just
from like just from a personal
perspective that was probably it was
just such a such a great bonding
experience for us
and what was that at the end of season
one yeah
there's only one season so
yeah yeah exactly jesus all right betsy
d loved everything you've been in from
hunger games to vikings to national
champions you're amazing however your
music is also fantastic
love let me be your whiskey we'll be
hearing more from you soon now you sort
of answered that but it sounds like
we're going to hear a lot more from you
and thank you yeah thank you so much
that
i just makes me so happy that people are
loving it i
yeah i
i'm not positive but i'm almost but i'm
pretty certain that we're releasing the
album next year again at one point it
becomes the labels call so i'm just
waiting to hear exactly when right
isn't it crazy to say i have a label
isn't that cool
dude
it's surreal surreal and if you played
live a lot or are you gonna start
playing yeah i know i i played
i played a show
uh in nashville uh a couple months ago i
opened up for um easton corbin in
georgia and douglas just just just to
get my feet wet and just you know are
you nervous as [ __ ]
the easton corbin one was more nervous
was like a thousand people and like i it
was like my first time playing with my
my guitars so that was a little bit more
nerve-wracking uh but the one that i
played in nashville was just a freaking
blast and jason played after too so that
was awesome do you wear cowboy boots
i wear my boots i don't know i wouldn't
call them i would just say boobs i would
say that they're like straight up cowboy
boots but they're the boots yeah i like
it lisa h what's it like working with
dwayne the rock johnson i met him once
he was really sweet but nice or scary or
intense what is it
oh amazing amazing that's another
example of somebody who is just a
consummate professional and just a
really really good human being i mean
dwayne
i when i did uh bad boys i i emailed him
and i just asked like what he does when
he works out because they asked me to
put on a stupid amount of weight so
quickly
um and he sent me a whole workout plan
you know he's that like a guy is one of
the busiest people on the planet and
it's like you don't have to do that so
oh he's an amazing amazing guy that's
awesome david h last question whose
mentorship have you gotten the most from
so far
um
the first people that come to mind for
me are
travis filmon and gustav skarsgard i'd
say gustaf a lot in my life he's a
brother to me and you know he's also
sober and he's he's just
a such a special human and then travis
is also one of my best friends but he
introduced me to my now acting coach
ibana and
um
he's he's just been a
a really really big part of my life as
well
last question i know i said last
question but uh i know you just told
michael rosenbaum on your podcast that
everyone was really cool that you've
worked with but really rob schneider in
grownups are you sure
actually i i never met rob because i was
in the second one um
and maybe
i don't even remember if he was in the
second one um but i i never i've never
met him before
sandler is one of the best people
did he give you the sandler yell
one word from the love of god oh yeah
yeah yeah and he actually he actually
called me a couple months ago to
congratulate me on the music you know
talk about another awesome dude
awesome dude he's he's amazing
yeah sandler jennifer lawrence man that
used to be my biggest crush ever did you
crush on her were you like totally
enamored by her
that's a no that's a no you weren't you
were busy working
yeah like i i i loved her like she was
so great but like jen and i only ever
worked for like 10 days together because
a lot of our scenes weren't together
until the end um
but she was such a sweetheart and so
talented and um
so funny right
so funny just so great but i would never
i wouldn't say that we made it to that
like stage of
you know friendship where you know i
just felt like we didn't even know each
other that well you know um
towards towards the end we definitely
became a little closer but like i i we
really didn't work together that much
gotcha so uh last but not least what's
what's coming up you got the music
coming up you got heals season two
coming up that you're gonna be filming
anything else
if scheduling permits i'm gonna be going
to spain
uh to shoot a uh a guy ritchie film uh
with uh jake gyllenhaal and i i
it's really cold cool i'll be the
interpreter um
so i'll be going to do that which i'm
really really excited about wow did you
have to audition for it i just got an
offer no i read to that did you have my
16 auditions
no no just one really just one audition
that was it you nailed it are you really
good at memorizing lines and and all
that [ __ ]
i mean get it good enough like i i think
i've done it enough that i don't play
too much
like i just i always believe in
preparation right so it's like
if i prepared enough by the time we end
up doing it it's like
i just i can just let it go and not
really
worry about anything have you ever taken
me that's
personally you know like for me like i'm
never there to get a job and there to
give a performance
and i think that that just that
mentality is
it certainly well brian i'm also
stealing that from brian cranston he
wrote that in his book and it's
a [ __ ] genius uh quote
wow well dude this has been great i hope
you had a good time dude i did man it's
so good so good talking to you yeah this
is great it was really great hopefully
we can get together sometime i told
steve and get me a part on heels i want
to you know come down and wrestle with
you guys i would love that for sure
i mean
i would imagine that they're going to
build that they're going to build that
uh
that uh that show out so yeah
cool characters that's got to be
exciting season two because they put a
lot of money and a lot of promotion into
that
you worked with pete siegel i love pete
pete still owes me pete still owes me a
role he promised his wife's my dentist
and uh
great dentist to beat a dentist yeah i
heard that i see she's not telling me
that like teeth i don't even live in l.a
like i would totally go see your body
she's beautiful and she's awesome she's
been my dentist forever and she's like a
a mom to me she's really awesome awesome
i went to college with his daughter and
she's amazing so i can only imagine that
her mom is awesome good family good
family all right dude well all my love i
wish you the best i'm excited for you
i'm gonna keep listening to the music
and uh
thanks for allowing me to be inside of
you man yes
thanks for being inside of me come back
inside anytime anytime you got it all
right buddy
see you guys see you man
i mean you can't really knock the guy
can you i mean he's gorgeous
he's got a fantastic body he can act he
can play music you can't hate the guy
he's got a lot of a lot of pluses
as far as dudes go he's doing all right
yeah right and i wish him the best
thank you for being on the podcast buddy
and um yeah he was uh
he was easy to talk to he's just a
genuine guy i really feel like i'm
talking to a dude just a regular guy who
just wants to chat and there's not any
you know preconceived or you know this
is the [ __ ] that people can carry
and kind of present
so i appreciate that uh also if you want
to join patreon the people who are
helping the podcast go to patreon.com
inside of you i love you patrons i'm
going to read your names off the top
patrons get their names read off at the
end of each show i appreciate it but
join patreon patreon.com inside i'll
write you a message right after go to
the inside of you online store for great
merch and the sunspin.com store for band
merch and zooms if you want to zoom with
me i'm also on the cameo i i do the
cameo you do the cameo i do the camera
you do the cameo
everybody's doing it
i mean everybody's doing why can't i do
it
um
good fun yeah
did you have a good week though
yeah they're okay week yeah are you
working a lot
yeah working a lot and
do you like it
yeah i mean i have things to look
forward to in the night you know i got a
soccer league going and i got isn't that
doesn't that help so much oh that's
great it really takes something like
it's a release i'm playing ice hockey a
little bit now and i was always a big
sports person growing up and just to
have them available to you i like being
a part of team and then it's exercise
and it's
we were shut down for a while with this
pandemic and now at least we do some
things that we love to do and i didn't
realize how much i appreciated them
until now yeah you're like oh my god
just
you know hanging out with your buds and
playing something competitive and just
for an hour and a half and sweating it
out and
what team sports are a blessing because
you get you get the physical activity
and the hangout like in one go in one go
yeah you gotta start softball again yes
what's that what's a good day for you
saturdays or sundays saturdays okay i
remember that yeah let's read the top
patrons these are the top patrons that
give uh the most back to the podcast i
really appreciate them and here we go
nancy d leah uh f
s correct
sorry leah nailed it sarah v little lisa
you kiko jill e brian d
h correct nico p robert
schmeichel no
robert
w
no b
correct and now jason
w correct kristen k amelia o allison el
raj c joshua d c j p jennifer n stacy l
gen
b s jamal
f correct janelle
b roger
rabbit
[Music]
um
s correct kimberly e mike eldon soprano
99 more ramirez san diego m chad w
leanne b correcta mundo janine r maya p
maddie s belinda and chris h dave h
spider-man chase sheila g brad d ray
ray h correct tabitha t tom
and liliana
m
n a a
i called you out on this last one you
didn't get it right betsy
d correct you've got it chad l rochelle
marion meg k trav l dan n
big stevie w angel m rhiannon c cory k
super sam coleman g dev nixon michelle a
jeremy c cody r gavinator david c john b
brandy d yvore camille s the c joey
pants joey m all right hi joey m willie
f christina e adelaide n omar i lena ann
eugene and leah chris p corey patricia
heather l jake b
got a few left here
try to remember these james b think
james brown
uh
bobbitt
bobbitt like lorena bobbitt
huh ed hasner ed a headache that a
mate
ebola f
joshua b
because he's cool
tony g sean r megan t mel s orlando c
annie john b caroline r darren b rob e
we love you all thanks patrons i
appreciate it thanks for spending um an
hour with us um ryan and i really
appreciate that
i do
yeah thanks for allowing me to be inside
of you all of you and until next time
from the hollywood hills in california
i'm michael rosenbaum i'm brian tails
that's
we love you guys and uh thanks thanks
for tuning in i really means a lot to me
go uh get people to subscribe will you
and most importantly
be good to you get vaccinated be good to
yourself what would you say also get
vaccinated well
just be good to yourself
we'll see you next week
[Music]